[Music]
jorge and vavara are with us hey guys
how are you great great thank you where
do you guys live in baltimore
awesomeness welcome to nashville how
much debt have you paid off two hundred
and thirty thousand dollars i love it
and how long did this take
three years and three months good for
you guys and your range of income during
that time
that's what happened many pan
so um we started combined income at 120
000
and then after
some side jobs
many side jobs and a lot of moon
lighting
we increased it at 180 thousand dollars
good for you what do you guys do for a
living
i am a researcher a medical i'm doing
medical research
and he's an electrical engineer awesome
very cool what kind of debt was your 230
000 oh it was a combination of
medical bills irs
credit cards lots of credit cards uh
401k loans uh in student loans uh most
of it was student loans saline and fed
loans wow
it was all my debt oh yours yes she
married into this huh
wow okay so now tell me this is not a
baltimore accent where are you guys from
i'm originally from russia
and he's from bolivia oh very cool and
how did you how did you two meet
um we met online actually
being in the us in the u.s oh very cool
how long have you been married
four years almost four years very good
and then you decide we're gonna go on
this journey three years and three
months ago and boom we hit this how did
you get connected to the ramsey stuff
well
i learned about you a little bit before
i met jorge
and
i just i just got it i paid off my only
one credit card and when i met him i was
so into dave ramsey that i started
talking about about you like on the
first date
oh no
that's true that's against the rules
you're not supposed to do that
and we signed up for a class no way yes
on the first day
yes
so
but
i uh for some reason we just didn't
follow through oh and uh after we
married and we were on a family vacation
and she can tell better
yeah we went into florida and family
vacation natasha was already born she
was two years old two months old
and there was a rainy day and um
we got this message we got the email
that we have two weeks left until the
dave ramsey membership expires so
and we're like okay let's let's just
watch it like give it a shot and we
started watching it
and
in two days we just binge watched the
whole the whole disc
and then we repeated the parts that we
wanted to hear again like
the first step and the second step the
baby step and we just kept watching it
and then started watching all we found
out about all the uh the debt free
screams and we just couldn't stop and we
just love that
you guys were all in so tell us about
the journey what did you guys do to get
out of debt oh
i
took maybe we don't have
i i did pizza delivery i did
amazon
jobs on the
weekends nights and holidays
uh i did uber driving and then i i
figured that i could do moonlighting and
i started doing moonlighting and that's
what
gave me the most with the coronavirus it
actually worked out
i shouldn't say that but it worked out
well
in the case that uh they were people
were more worked out well for the
plexiglas people too so it's okay
there was so much work in amazon
they needed people and so i took
as many shifts as i could and then uh
for the
moonlighting i do uh
cat drafting and
revit uh modeling
and i i started just doing my own beam
consulting uh gig and uh
it just
when the coronavirus hit
the businesses were more willing to uh
hire me remote
and i just went gasoline pants that's
amazing so y'all watched financial peace
multiple times you worked around the
clock did people think you were crazy
definitely yeah definitely yes
um 230 000 in three years that's
impressive yes i mean you've lived on
nothing oh yeah oh my goodness yeah we
lived before when we just married we
wanted to have nice live you know we we
live in like almost like good apartment
in suburbs yeah with 1600 square feet
but once we got in the journey
we moved from this to the city to
baltimore in the shoebox basically it
was 400 feet no ac
it was it was
almost inhumane like our our parents
thought we were nuts
because she was five months when we
moved and they they refused to come for
for a while because it was just no cost
it was really uncomfortable we didn't
even have a table to eat dinner or lunch
we were eating the couch we sold
everything on craigslist i saw all my
ins i played music i play guitar and
drums and i sold all my instruments uh
because i didn't even have the space and
i was working so much that i didn't have
time to play with them anyway so i just
gave up all of that
um yeah it was
was it worth it oh yes
because now i can go to a guitar center
and buy myself
a better guitar
anything you want anything you want
doesn't make you make a couple hundred
thousand dollars a year and you don't
have any debt yes yeah that puts you in
a completely and you got a baby i mean
life is good and nothing but a beautiful
opportunity in front of you yes yeah you
two are amazing thank you thank you
amazing oh and we tripled my income of
course for sure
so what do you tell people who think it
can't be done who feel like they're
overwhelmed you know maybe multiple six
figures in debt like you all had what do
you tell them right now
well
first
get on the get on the budget
and just just do it don't question it
don't question it because we knew people
who started doing that and just start
analyzing it too much doing too much
math it's not mathematical yeah just
just do it just follow it like this
you know it works and i don't know how
to convince other people that it just
works it works
i think you guys just go to work
yeah look at the look at the uh the
weather forecast and when you see rain
in florida go get in the hotel room and
binge watch fpu and that that's that's
the formula right there yeah
yeah i love it also i would i would say
we we were watching a lot of day free
screams a lot dead free screams
oatmeal
every morning it was a routine natasha
was one year old one year all already
yes
and we were eating the same oatmeal
every morning and we're watching just
day free scream like crazy people i will
not eat oatmeal anymore
i love it all right i love it beautiful
all right let's bring beautiful natasha
up and uh what a great russian name to
your heritage there i love it natasha
she's a princess
how beautiful is she now how old is she
now she's three and a half
so you have a new country
you have a new marriage
you have a new baby
and you have a new future
you guys are pretty cool
thank you this is pretty neat you got
opportunity in front of you like
nobody's business medical researcher
electrical engineer uh you guys can do
any thing you want to do i'm actually in
pa school now i decided to switch
careers she stopped working why not some
time ago where cash flowing we were
paying off debt and cash flow in her
school okay well why not i like it very
well done you guys are something else i
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you that's the next chapter in your
story for sure you'll be there in 20
minutes the way you two are rolling
you're fun to watch all right it's jorge
and varvara and natasha from baltimore
230 000 paid off in three years three
months making 120 to 180 what a
wonderful story count it down let's hear
a debt-free scream
one two three